in an alternate timeline the U.S and
Russia are still at each other's throats
a full-blown war is not an option for
both of them so they have reverted to
spying but the traditional spies have
also become outdated and easy to catch
hence the Russians have formed a group
of female spies who have mastered The
Art of Seduction they find their targets
seduce them have coitus with them and
then extract the required information
sounds like a pretty good deal for the
victims the opening scene introduces
Dominica igorova a prominent ballet
dancer from Russia ever since her teens
she has been dancing and taking care of
her ailing mother one day Dominica
entrusts her mother to a caretaker and
heads to work she meets with various
guests including her Uncle Ivan who
serves as the deputy director of
Russia's foreign intelligence service
svr during the meet and greet a gangster
named Dimitri Ustinov asks Dominica for
a picture and uses the opportunity to
touch her inappropriately shortly after
the performance begins and Dominica
dances beautifully impressing the
audience unfortunately soon her dance
partner jumps and lands on her leg
breaking it badly as a result Dominica
is rushed to the hospital for emergency
surgery following this we are introduced
to Nate Nash a CIA agent working in
Moscow one day as he is about to meet
one of his assets in Gorky Park he is
unexpectedly confronted by the police
swiftly thinking on his feet Nate
creates a distraction by firing shots at
the ground this ensures the safety of
the Russian mole codenamed marble who
escapes without being identified however
nade is taken into custody by the
authorities during the chaos he is then
escorted to the safety of the American
Embassy where he meets his superiors
they inform him that marble is safe but
he is to be deported back to the U.S due
to his mistake the next day Ivan visits
the director of the svr and general
Vladimir korchnoy they show him video
footage of Nate's meeting in Gorky Park
and explained that their primary
interest lies in the unidentified
individual the scene then shifts back to
Dominica who wakes up in a hospital bed
to discover that her leg is now encased
in a metal frame she is devastated when
she realizes that she will never dance
again months pass but Dominica is still
walking with the help of a Cane one day
Uncle Ivan visits her and reveals that
her replacement has been found which
means that her workplace will no longer
provide her with any benefits hence he
offers to help Dominica and asks her to
come to him once she's ready before
leaving though he hands her an envelope
containing intimate pictures of her
former dance partner and her replacement
as well as a recording of their
conversation which implies that her
partner intentionally caused the
accident so that his girlfriend could
take her place this Revelation angers
Dominica so she goes straight to the
theater to keep an eye on her former
partner and his girlfriend after
watching them practice she follows them
to the steam room where they start
making out in a fit of rage Dominica
attacks them with her cane exacting her
Vengeance on her way back she stops by a
phone booth and reports the incident as
an accident
whoopsie after this Dominica now with
her career in Ruins turns to her uncle
for help he agrees to his sister but
only if she returns the favor the svr is
interested in gaining more information
on the gangster from earlier Dimitri so
he asks Dominica to befriend him and
earn his trust using her feminine charms
though hesitant to Dominica has no other
choice as her mother's medical expenses
are too damn high that night Dominica
goes to the hotel where Dimitri is
staying dressed beautifully and heads to
the bar to catch his eye as she expected
Dimitri approaches her and asks how he
can assist her she expresses her desire
to feel special once again and they
proceed to a private room leaving
Dimitri's guards outside after a while
he asks her to undress and immediately
gets to work like a madman but right
then a person wearing a black helmet
enters the room and murders Dimitri the
Intruder then throws a coat at Dominica
to cover her bloodied body and rescues
her through the back door the man turns
out to be an svr agent named Constantine
sent by Ivan soon after Ivan comes to
Dominica and presents her with a choice
either become an svr operative or face
execution for witnessing Dimitri's
murder as expected she chooses to work
for them following this Dominica is
enrolled in the harsh and rigorous State
School 4 which specializes in training
sparrows svr operatives skilled in using
sex bienage to seduce their targets I'm
sorry that was awesome upon her arrival
she is greeted by matron the
headmistress of sparrow who gives her a
new identity and leads her inside the
very next day classes commenced and
matron delivers a speech on the current
world chaos emphasizing how Russia is
the only country willing to make
sacrifices to fix it she also announces
to the students that their bodies now
belong to the state and they are
obligated to perform any task assigned
to them in the next scene Nate meets
with a CIA panel who decides to suspend
him for his blunder in Russia however
Nate argues that he has worked with
marble for years and that nobody else
can be trusted his plea is eventually
taken into consideration and he has
given his second chance to redeem
himself Nate is then assigned to the
nearest city Budapest to re-establish
contact with marble but unknown to them
their every move is being monitored by
the svr back in State School 4 matron
teaches The Sparrows how to identify
what their target wants she displays
several images on TV and asks them to
identify their wants the first one is
incorrectly answered by an arrogant
student named Victor and Dominica
correct him this makes him the laughing
stock in front of everyone another
female student correctly guesses the
second and she is summoned to the front
of the class in order to satisfy a guy
the girl gets down on her knees however
she is unable to do so the following day
the students are asked to welcome a
troop of soldiers who have recently
returned from combat Dominica selects a
young man and takes him to a private
room where she pleases him later the
performance is observed by matron and
the other students matron comments on
dominica's performance saying that her
technique was good but she still hasn't
learned to give herself up after class
as Dominica is taking a shower big
Victor comes from behind and tries to
assault her but she bravely defends
herself by hitting him with a water tap
this incident causes a huge uproar and
general Vladimir himself arrives at the
school to investigate he asks Dominica
why she did it to which she responds
that she serves this state not her
fellow students in the next class
Dominica is called to the front by
matron while Vladimir watches through a
CCTV camera matron presents a picture of
Victor and asks Dominica to identify his
desires just then Victor is brought into
the room and matron orders Dominica to
give him what he wants our protagonist
undresses herself and sits on the table
with her legs open egging him to take
her however Victor who is still
terrified from the earlier incident
leaves without even touching her
Dominica then answers matron's question
that he wants power this impresses
Vladimir so he assigns her to a mission
in Budapest her job is to gain Nate's
trust and reveal Marvel's identity maybe
a masculate a few more a-holes while
you're at it agreeing to the mission
Dominica travel levels to Budapest and
shares his accommodation with a fellow
Sparrow Marta under the supervision of
svr station Chief Maxim volondov she
then begins following Nate and goes to
the same swimming pool where he goes she
intentionally bumps into him and has a
brief chat pretending to be a translator
for the embassy the next day Dominica
heads to the swimming pool but doesn't
find Nate there furthermore she learns
that her idea is missing it turns out
that Nate has already figured out that
she's a Russian spy trying to uncover
Marvel's identity he reports this to his
superiors and recognizes her potential
value hearing this his superiors Grant
him permission to get closer to Dominica
to gather more information later
Dominica visits the embassy and
discovers Marta talking with an American
politician named Stephanie Boucher not
long after Nate approaches Dominica and
confesses to taking her ID from the pool
upon realizing that he's aware of her
Mission she reveals her true intentions
the two then have a short conversation
and agree to meet for dinner the
following day afterwards Dominica
returns to her apartment and searches
Marta's room where she she discovers
that Marta has been tasked with buying
confidential information from Stephanie
the next day after work she tails the
station Chief Maxim to a bar and
requests him to provide her more time by
sending a good report to Moscow in order
to make him do so Dominica prods him
into hitting her now that his act is
caught on cameras she blackmails him
into sending a better report or else
she'll turn him into the police
meanwhile Nate is waiting for her at the
restaurant but when she doesn't show up
for a long time he leaves assuming that
she ditched him unbeknownst to him
Dominica follows him to his place she
rings the doorbell and he covertly lets
her in Nate frantically inquires how she
found his place and Dominica turns up
the TV volume to ensure that they can't
be overheard before asking him about
what happened in Gorky Park after
receiving the answer she kisses him but
he stops her Midway and asks her to go
home the following day Dominica receives
an unexpected visit from Ivan who wants
to check on her progress with Nate
feeling pressured to buy more time she
makes up a lie and tells him that she's
also working on Stephanie's case with
Marta but will require additional
funding Ivan gives it some thought and
decides to leave for now while getting
his coat Dominica manages to sneak a
look at his passport to gather Intel on
him later that evening Dominica returns
home to shockingly find Marta's lifeless
body in the bathtub before she can even
comprehend what happened Constantine the
same svr agent from earlier appears from
behind and grabs her by the neck he then
explains that this is what happens to
those who share secrets meanwhile Nate
informs his superiors about Marvel's new
message which confirms that Dominica is
a sparrow although his superiors view
her as a threat Nate believes that she's
still recruitable the next evening he
brings Dominica to her apartment and
admits that he knows her real identity
Dominica in turn reveals her story
emphasizing that her only concern is her
mother's safety Nate then offers her a
deal to become a double agent for him
promising her protection in return after
thinking it over Dominica asks if she
can trust him he assures her that she
can and the two end up becoming intimate
in the morning Dominica meets with
Nate's superiors who subject her to a
lie detector test to assess her
reliability is this film a poorly
cobbled together spy story that's using
your body to sell tickets yes she's
telling the truth sir when she passes
the test she asks for money claiming
that she can buy them information from
Stephanie Boucher on Friday Dominica
travels to London with Maxim to meet
Stephanie and execute the transaction
she stays in a hotel room that the CIA
has specially prepared for her with
security cameras and a set of discs
hidden under a desk which she can swap
for the real ones later shortly after
Stephanie arrives at the hotel and
Dominica approaches her claiming that
she was sent by Marta once Stephanie is
convinced she hands over the discs in
exchange for the money Dominica pretends
to authenticate the discs but in reality
she switches them with the fake ones
after the deal Stephanie realizes that
she's being monitored by American
intelligence agents in a state of panic
she throws the money in the trash and
tries to cross the street but
unfortunately she only ends up getting
hit by a truck and dying on the spot
guess she should have looked both ways
Russian agents watching the whole
incident assumed that their mission has
been compromised they also suspect that
Dominica and Maxim were the ones who
tipped off the Americans so the two are
ordered to return to Moscow upon their
arrival Ivan seizes the discs and
apprehends both Dominica and Nate
despite their protests of Innocence they
endure excruciating torture for days and
Maxim is even executed however Dominica
remains adamant in her denial of
involvement with the Americans
eventually Ivan begins to believe her
and allows her to go back to Budapest to
carry out her original Mission of
extracting Marble's identity Upon
returning with Nate Dominica enjoys a
romantic evening with him at his
residence however in the middle of the
night she wakes up to discover
Constantine subjecting Nate to torture
in order to obtain Marvel's identity at
first Dominica feign's complicity with
complicity yeah with Constantine and
even assists in inflicting harm on Nate
but when he is distracted she assaults
him enabling Nate to break free from
from his restraints the two then team up
against Constantine and managed to take
him down but they endure serious
injuries during this process in the next
scene Dominica wakes up at the hospital
where she receives a surprise visit from
General Vladimir shockingly he reveals
himself as the mole marble Vladimir who
is a former patriotic official confesses
that he became disillusioned with
Russia's rampant corruption when his
sick wife was denied treatment from an
American doctor fearing that he will
soon be caught and his sacrifice will be
in vain Vladimir instructs Dominica to
expose him to Ivan doing so would make
her a national hero and allow her to
replace him as a mole Dominica thinks
the idea is absurd but after a lot of
convincing she decides to turn herself
into the authorities she asks to speak
to the Russian Ambassador and when her
wish is granted she explains that she
has the name of the mole however she
will only reveal his name in exchange
for her freedom in the aftermath of the
conversation an exchange meeting is
scheduled at an airport Nate is assigned
to accompany Dominica in order to
confirm the moles identity he is deeply
upset as he feels used and betrayed by
dominica's actions he feels used that's
rich however she is a surprise for him
shortly after the Russians approached
them with the mole whose face when
uncovered turns out to be Ivan it is
revealed that Dominica had been
fabricating evidence to frame her uncle
ever since she arrived in Budapest and
even blamed him for the botched Exchange
in London shocked Nate quickly confirms
Ivan as the mole and just after the
exchange Ivan is shot by a Russian
sniper after the exchange ends Dominica
is taken away in a helicopter in the
final scene we see her being honored in
a Russian military ceremony attended by
General Vladimir Dominica is now living
a good and free life with her mother
something which she had always dreamed
of
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching